this video is sponsored by the book
summary service blinkist the first 100
people to use the link in the
description will receive one free week
of unlimited access plus 25% off of Full
membership positioned at the Forefront
of perhaps the most significant shift in
Western history having both predicted
the cause and consequence and going on
to provide grandiose revolutionary ideas
as possible solutions Fredick n is one
of the most influential and significant
thinkers of modern history
the particular Crossroads that n stands
at is one where the primary path of
Western religious Faith began to crumble
and cave in leaving a massive empty
crater at the end of life's suffering
and what would seem like only one
alternative path towards that of
pessimism and nihilism his life's work
would undertake this newly emerging
issue and attempt to forge a new third
path away from both religious faith and
nihilism and towards new meaning and
human
values n was bornn in 1844 in Saxony
Prussia which is now part of Eastern
Germany he was born to a modest family
living in ordinary sheltered Early
Childhood his father Carl ludvig n was
the town's Lutheran Pastor which would
immediately immerse young n into the
Christian faith however simultaneous to
being introduced to it it would soon be
challenged and tested as his father the
same man who practiced and preached of
God was diagnosed with a terminal brain
disease for a year his father suffered
horribly and then died at the young age
of just 35 and the following year n's
younger brother ludvig also died this
dichotomy of his religious Foundation an
early exposure to the irreconcilable
reasonless pain and suffering
experienced by good undeserving people
would likely lay some of the groundwork
for what would ultimately become the
basis of n's later work following a
fairly somber serious and lonely
childhood n would go on to study
theology at the University of bond both
in early schooling and University he
would show strong intellectual promise
excelling especially well in Christian
theology however following just one
semester at University as he became
increasingly critical and intellectually
sharp and after being exposed to various
critiques of Christianity n would have
no choice but to let go of his Christian
faith fully shedding the skin of his
innocence and blind devotion from here
he would go on to study philology the
study of the history of language at the
University of leipsig here he would do
well that while still only in his
mid-20s he would go on to be hired as a
professor of classical philology at the
University of bosil becoming the
youngest Professor to ever be hired
still to this day after only a few years
of teaching though n would leave his
position partly because of his growing
dissatisfaction and sense of constraint
within Academia and partly because of
his growing poor health which he had
accumulated by a combination of genetic
ailments and what is believed to have
been a case of syphilis that he
contracted out of brothel from here he
would go on to live a fairly isolated
life traveling around Europe moving to
and from different climates most
suitable for his poor health and living
off his small University pension he
would live primarily and most notably in
the Swiss Alps where he would spend the
majority of his remaining sane life
throughout this time in between spells
of being bedridden by his ailments a
devastating failed love ordeal degrading
friendships and family relations and
depressive and nihilistic States n would
spend most of his time walking thinking
and writing finding Solace meaning and
reason to continue through his pursuit
of philosophy during this time he would
produce his most influential Works
including human all to human the gay
science Thus Spoke zarathustra Beyond
Good and Evil and on the genealogy of
morals in these Works n would lay both
the groundwork and early constructions
of a new sort of philosophy a philosophy
that would essentially loosen the bolts
of all contemporary certainties all
Notions of Good and Evil
all knowledge of true and false right
and wrong God is dead God remains dead
and we have killed him how shall we
Comfort ourselves the murderers of all
murderers what was holiest and mightiest
of all that the world has yet owned has
bled to death under our knives is not
the greatness of this deed too great for
us must we ourselves not become Gods
simply to appear worthy of it this is
perhaps one of n's most quoted and
important passages it is in this line
line God is dead that we find not n's
celebration of Humanity's lost faith but
his Stark intense concern of warning for
what it meant the collapse of Christian
faith brought with it in n's mind the
collapse of everything built on it the
whole of European morality its rationals
and its values he both predicted and
feared that with this Collective
Revelation without sufficient
replacement Humanity would be left to
struggle with no clear system or meaning
and devolve into widespread disp
in the form of nihilism one of n's key
ideas at the foundation of his attempt
to resolve this issue is the recognition
that there is in fact no Universal
objective truth to be known there are no
facts only interpretations he wrote n
denied the very construct of any sort of
capital T truth and suggested that all
attempts to find one were woefully
misguided and actually the source of
Disconnect preventing Modern Man from
rediscovering any meaning in life the
pursuit of universal objectivity or
meaning Beyond this life took the spirit
out of the present Earthly Human
Experience of meaning which is
inherently subjective independent and
expressive because of this n would
direct his attention primarily to the
Arts and Humanities believing that
creative acts and experiences be it
things like music philosophy literature
theater and so on could be used as
essential means to communicate deeper
truths and fill the void of higher
connection and meaning although as n
explored this theory he would find that
cultural Arts and Humanities were
susceptible to becoming dried out
academic and or commodified often losing
their luster and dependability from here
he would turn his attention towards
creating a philosophy that detached the
individual from dependence on any
collective experience or cultural
mechanisms and rather focused on the
individual pursuit of creative
expression and subjective greatness
placing the creation of meaning squarely
in the hands of each
individual this philosophy would be
embodied in what need would term the
Uber mench or Overman or sometimes
translated as the Superman which he
would first introduce in his book Thus
Spoke zaratustra the Overman is
described as a sort of defiant confident
independent individual who pursues their
personal desires with Vigor and
dignifies their independent beliefs
unapologetically one who deviates from
the collective exhibits strategic
selfishness and acts with aggressiveness
and grandiose the reason for such
characteristics was justified in n's
view by the fact that a new morality
that opposed the moral views rooted in
Christianity which praised weakness and
modesty was needed to better suit the
natural condition of human experience
which he felt was comprised and
requiring of the desire for Vigor power
and
greatness this view is not without valid
critiques and invalid
misinterpretations however perhaps what
is more important than n's image of the
Overman is what the concept serves to
represent in slightly broader terms nche
sets up the Overman to function as a
sort of idealized version of oneself an
image of a perfect and Powerful being
who has overcome all their fears and
deficiencies which one can and should
set goals to strive towards of course as
an ideal it cannot ever truly be reached
but that is functionally the point n
proposed that the world including the
human operates off of what he called the
will to power an insatiable desire in
each living being to manifest power the
world is Will To Power and nothing
besides he wrote and according to n this
will to power is manifested in the
desire for personal growth and satisfied
in the pursuance of said growth it is
important to note here that his notion
of power is not necessarily referring to
physical strength nor power in dominance
over others but rather power over
oneself psychological and spiritual
strength in the form of self-mastery and
continuous growth represents the
ultimate synchronization with the will
to power for n and thus the ultimate
synchronization with life itself the
desire and striving towards the ideal of
the Overman serves as Perpetual fuel to
this process of self-growth as one works
through a continued cycle of self-
dissatisfaction self-improvement and
self- rediscovery over and over forn
this process which he would term
self-overcoming is fundamental to
answering and resolving the problem of
meaning and value in life so long as one
establishes their goals of growth in the
name of what they deem an idealized life
affirming version of them themselves the
process transmutes the suffering of life
into something worthwhile and personally
redeemable a sort of alchemy of the
spirit that affirms life in the face of
its inevitable suffering if we have our
own why in life we shall get along with
almost any how n wrote unlike his
primary predecessor Arthur schopenhauer
who proposed that suffering is best
minimized and avoided to the best of
one's ability n argued that suffering is
rather a good thing to be leaned into
embraced and used as fuel towards the
amassing of strength and psychological
power life is in fact inevitable
suffering and so it is not a matter of
if but for what the meaninglessness of
suffering not suffering itself was the
curse that lay over mankind so far n
wrote while continuing to write and live
an increasingly isolated life in the
mountains still in the early stages of
some of his most ambitious philosophical
undertakings n would begin to show
increasing signs of declining mental
Health at 44 years old after seeing a
horse being flogged in a street by its
owner he experienced a mental breakdown
rushing over to the horse hugging and
consoling it and yelling I understand
you I understand you this strange
episode which marked his last moments
out of apparent Lucidity appeared to be
an act of complete contradiction to his
own philosophy pity weakness and
compassion soon after n would dip into
complete Madness eventually falling into
a state of cat Tonia one of the most
powerful minds of modern history
seemingly collapsed under the weight of
itself whether the cause was organic
latent consequences to his contracted
ailments or the consequence of a mind
that pursued too far into itself
becoming stuck on its way back out is
unknown before ever coming back out in
1900 at the young age of 55 n died of a
stroke during his lifetime according to
his own standards n might likely be
considered a failure
prior to losing his sanity he had made
very little of himself and saw very
little if not no success his books
didn't sell and he never really garnered
any notable respect or recognition but
following his death of course his work
would take off soon gaining massive
notice respect and worldwide following
some of which unfortunately would lead
to horrible misguided and ill-conceived
applications however today and more
generally nich's work remains potent
important and redeema ingrained in
modern thinking his quotes aphorisms and
ideas echo through culture every day
both literally and symbolically and so
in a fittingly ironic way just how nche
suggested that we must symbolically die
throughout life so that we can get out
of our own way and become who we really
are sometimes sacrificing ourself our
personal preservation health or sanity
in the process of something greater
perhaps n's life and death was just that
a process of self-overcoming towards
self self-sacrifice towards something
greater of course n's ideas aren't
without valid critiques including this
notion of self-overcoming sacrifice and
greatness although his assessments and
predictions of modern issues are
arguably quite accurate his resolutions
aren't necessarily all serving is
suffering and the continual pursuit of
desire and self-destruction in the name
of growth towards an unattainable end
goal really a good thing and how can one
see it as a good thing if they do not
how can one create a life affirming
interpretation of life if their
interpretation of life is not affirming
in other words if one sees life as
negative or meaningless to try to create
goals or place themselves on such an
interpretation only brings them back to
square one in need of some truth or
meaning Beyond themselves something
other than what one sees has or
experiences which they cannot have and
furthermore if one does not agree with
the initial premise that suffering is
good in the name of progress then the
rest might merely be
misdirection of course being a
philosopher whose work doesn't
necessarily follow any linear or
systematic structure and can even
contradict itself at times n's ideas are
open to multiple interpretations and of
course all the afor mentioned is merely
a single very brief one and more
importantly seeing as how his philosophy
caters to this open-ended nature and is
arguably not a guide to think in a
certain way but rather a guide to think
in One's Own Way n leaves us the space
to even if we disagree with him do just
as he did and pave a new direction for
[Music]
ourself this video was sponsored by
blinkist few people deny the value of
healthy reading and learning habits but
for most of us it is understandably
difficult to sustain the negative
feedback loop between feeling like you
don't have enough time time to
consistently read and learn and the
potential value that reading and
learning could have on reducing or
better managing this sense that you
don't have enough time for things you
value is unfortunately paradoxical the
book summary service blinkist however
makes escaping this cycle much easier
condensing thousands of non-fiction
books into around 15minute summaries
that can be read or listened to even
while offline blinkist makes it easy to
absorb and grasp the ideas and key
takeaways of complete books in a
convenient amount of time whether you're
interested in philosophy science
psychology business art or any other
common non-fiction subjects blink can
help just about anyone better learn and
consistently engage in their Curiosities
better yet blinkist now also provides
complete audio books that you can
purchase directly within the app as well
as Consolidated summaries of popular
podcasts allowing you to fully delve
into topics and authors that you find
especially fascinating if you're
interested in learning more about topics
related to philosophy and Western
history blinkist has some great titles
including at the existential Cafe by
Sarah bwell which explores the lives and
ideas of popular 20th century
existential thinkers as well as a brief
history of thought by Luke Ferry which
explores the history and key
developments of Western philosophy more
broadly and how we can apply it to our
everyday lives the first 100 people to
use the link in the description will
receive one free week of unlimited
access as well as 25% off of Full
membership the free 7-Day trial can be
cancelled at any time within the trial
period
again if you're interested please visit
blink.com pursuit of Wonder or click the
link in the description below and of
course thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
[Music]